a world filled with reverent statues
convoluted family trees and mischievous
halflings episode 3 of the rings of
power has more of tolkien's lore at work
than you may have recognized
anyone who's watched peter jackson's the
lord of the rings trilogy is familiar
with the epic scene in the return of the
king where pippin lights the beacons of
gondor the little halfling scales a
watchtower and tosses a flame onto a
pile of brushwood without the guard
seeing him this sets off a string of
similar firebound watchtowers which send
a visual message to king theoden in
rohan that gondor calls for aid the
scene is also mirrored in the opening
chapter of the return of the king book
although in this case pippin observes
the lit beacons from afar rather than
lighting them himself
[Music]
knuckles
in either case the opportunity to light
some beacons is too good to miss and it
should come as no surprise that the
rings of power found its own way to
sneak some lit beacons into its
adaptation in episode three when
galadriel and hal brand arrive in
numenor on elendil's ship they pass a
watchtower out at sea as they look up lo
and behold a beacon is burning in this
case it's likely a lighthouse beacon
designed for ships but the callback to
peter jackson's films is difficult to
miss
the elves aren't the only ones with
special statues while linden is littered
with gorgeous wooden carvings numenor
has a lot of its own sculptures mostly
chiseled right into stone in episode
three as allendale's ship sails down the
narrow waterway that leads into the
heart of his home island viewers can see
giant statues of heads perched along the
route full-blown forms are also shown
including a gigantic statue just as the
ship arrives at the main port this last
statue was a central point of
speculation for months after it first
showed up in the show's original super
bowl ad in early 2022 guesses as to the
statue's identity spanned the gamut
numenor has a lot of kings and queens
after all but there are a couple of
details that make one regal figure the
clear front-runner first there's a giant
statue of a bird next to the humanoid
figure second if you look closely there
appears to be a small item bound to the
figure's forehead this indicates that
we're looking at a statue of e arendyl
one of tolkien's most important
middle-earth heroes his wife is elwing
who is turned into a bird at one point
he's also the father of elrond and his
twin brother elros who is the first king
of numenor and the relic on his forehead
e arendil ends up sailing through the
heavens on his ship with one of the
shining jewels the silmarils on his brow
when isildor first shows up it's early
in episode 3 when we see the young cadet
preparing for the sea trials with his
shipmates when the exercise is completed
they sail to shore and stand facing the
water while the drill sergeant blows on
a horn and pays homage to the massive
body of water before
him the sea
is always right
the scene is always right
the easter egg here is tucked into the
drill sergeant's accessories
specifically his shell-shaped musical
instrument the choice of a shell isn't
just a fun way to show off the
numenorean penchant for sea travel it's
a detail that connects right back to one
of the most important beings in all of
middle earth ulmo ulmo is one of the
valar the angelic beings who function as
guardians of middle earth ulmo is called
the lord of waters and his power extends
throughout all of the oceans seas and
tributaries of the world and what does a
being as epic as ulmo the lord of waters
use to get some attention why giant
seashells of course the silmarillion
says that at times umo will come to
middle earth and there make music upon
his great horns the ulumuri that are rot
of white shell and those to whom that
music comes hear it ever after in their
hearts and longing for the sea never
leaves them again
when we arrive in numenor in episode
three there are a lot of sights to take
in all at once one of these is a
stunningly vibrant tree with white
petals the concept of a white tree isn't
new to tolkien fans even casual viewers
of the films in peter jackson's the
return of the king a white tree can be
seen in the center of a court in minos
tirith except this time we're looking at
a corpse not a thriving living organism
the two images aren't just similar
either they're actually related that's
right the dead white tree of gondor can
trace its roots back to its ancestors
seen in numenor in the rings of power
the numenorean iteration of the arboreal
wonder is called nimloth and it's
brought to numenor by the elves as a
gift from valinor eventually isildur
takes a fruit of nimloth with him to
middle-earth where he plants it in minos
ethio when that fortress is captured and
becomes the headquarters of the nazgul
the tree is destroyed but one of its
fruits survives and is planted in menos
tirith
in the rings of power numenor is led by
queen regent muriel when galadriel and
hal brand first arrive in episode 3
muriel talks to elendil about the
struggle that her people have with
trusting
elves though elves have been unwelcome
on our shore since the reign of my
grandfather's great grandfather
this feels like an eloquently written
throwaway line meant to emphasize how
serious it is that a lendel brought an
elf back to numenor but as with all
things tolkien things go much deeper
than that the author traced the entire
line of numenorean kings in his writings
which means we can take a quick stroll
back up the family tree to see who
muriel's grandfather's great grandfather
is and it turns out that it's a not so
nice fellow named ara dunicore in the
book unfinished tales tolkien explains
that in this reign the elven tongues
were no longer used nor permitted to be
taught but were maintained in secret by
the faithful and the ships from oreccia
came seldom and secretly to the west
shores of numenor thereafter when muriel
specifically highlights that her great
great great grandfather started the
antipathy toward the elves it isn't a
line that the writers created out of
whole cloth it's a deliberate reference
to a grumpy numenorean king who ruled
long before the rings of power story
ever starts
when galadriel visits the western
regions of numenor with alendil the pair
of travelers visit the hall of lore a
library and depository of information
that elrose the first king of numenor
himself created while the actual hall is
made up for the show elrose is very much
a tolkien original he's the brother of
elrond and a character that comes from a
very complicated family tree that
includes elves men and even the angelic
mayar while elrond chooses the immortal
life of an elf though elrose opts for
the mortality of being a man along with
choosing the mystery of the gift of
death elros also becomes a mighty king
who founds numenor and lives for five
centuries by the time of the rings of
power elrose has been gone for a long
while even as his twin brother still
serves as gilgalad's herald back in
linden this leads to an interesting line
when galadriel and elendil look at a
tapestry of the twin brothers in the
hall of lore galadriel confirms that she
knew elrose but makes an interesting
statement
but i was always closer with his brother
[Music]
for savvy viewers this is a quiet
connection to galadriel's already
established friendship with elrond but
it goes even deeper in the source
material elrond eventually marries
galadriel's daughter and the two will go
on to serve on the white council and
generally resist sauron side by side
over the millennia to say she's closer
to elrond is an understatement
early in season one the harfoot leader
saddak burrows tells an endlessly
inquisitive nori brandyfoot that the
stars are strange the foreboding words
materialize in the form of the stranger
who crash lands from the sky right near
the harfoot community nori takes the
stranger under her tiny yet formidable
wing and in episode 3 it comes out that
she's been helping the odd super-powered
giant in the fallout zadek faces off
against nori reprimanding her in front
of the entire clan at one point nori's
father largo chimes in pointing out that
the whole situation is extraordinary
before asking if he'd ever seen beings
falling from the stars sedek has an
interesting response
a pair the beans who had turned into
stars
never the other way around
the reference to beings becoming stars
feels random but once again it could be
a quiet easter egg pointing to tolkien's
famous sailor of the firmament yarendill
the hero ends his epic first stage
career by having a shining silmaril
bound to his forehead before his ship
sails off into the heavens over
middle-earth in effect turning him into
a star the thought that a random
har-foot leader in an isolated community
would somehow know about e arendelle
seems unlikely but the line could still
be left behind for those to find it who
can
toward the end of episode 3 we see
nori's mother marigold confront her
about her actions with a stranger asking
if she thinks it's destiny and that
she's somehow special the little
harford's response is telling
i know
i'm not special
i know i'm just one little harefoot in a
grand wide world
for fans of tolkien's canon the line
echoes another spoken by gandalf at the
end of the hobbit on the last page of
that book gandalf and some of the
dwarves come back to visit their burglar
friend in the shire bilbo expresses
surprise that so many things they hoped
to happen had come true at which point
the grey wizard interjects and why
should not they prove true surely you
don't disbelieve the prophecies because
you had a hand in bringing them about
yourself gandalf goes on to highlight
the larger purpose behind bilbo's story
saying you don't really suppose do you
that all your adventures and escapes
were managed by mere luck just for your
sole benefit you are a very fine person
mr baggins and i'm very fond of you but
you are only quite a little fellow in a
wide world after all this concept of a
higher purpose runs throughout tolkien's
stories and it's cool to see the larger
theme reflected in nori's small yet
significant story
when galadriel visits hal brandon prison
the center of the room is filled with a
giant statue of a blue mermaid looking
female figure positioned as if she's
swimming it's an odd sight in the jail
but it may be there to help calm the
occupants in their cells why because it
looks an awful lot like the maya uenen
an angelic being known for bringing
peace and calm to turbulent waters
uwinnin is married to the violent maya
osei who has a reputation for causing
storms at sea the silmarillion describes
owen as the counterpoint to her spouse
adding osei's spouse is owenan the lady
of the seas whose hair lies spread
through all waters under sky all
creatures she loves that live in the
salt streams and all weeds that grow
there to her mariners cry for she can
lay calm upon the waves restraining the
wildness of osei the flattering
description ends with the line the
numenoreans lived long in her protection
and held her in reverence equal to the
valar while it could just be a random
statue the fact that she's loved by the
men of numenor and even details like the
seaweed in her hair seemed to reinforce
the idea that we're looking at an easter
egg visualization of the lady of the
seas
[Music]